the middle I'll come to the lab peace be
with you welcome to another episode of
the Dene show and my next guest coming
out at the young age of 20 accepted this
Dean this beautiful way of life this
practice about over 1.5 billion people
all across the globe and he started to
ponder and think and started asking
those serious questions purpose of life
have you ever wondered have you asked
those questions where did I come from
where am I going when I die
we're replete with everything else money
cars jewelry bling bling but at the age
of 20 this young man started to think
about purpose and now he accepted the
Dean and he's on the Dean show all the
way from Serbia he was born in Serbia
raised in Hungary actually in Toronto
and you know what we're just going to
wait bring him out he's going to tell us
the rest because we got an exciting show
with our next guest Esau Greg here on
the Dean show
[Music]
this is the thing this is the thing this
is the thing
[Music]
back here on addy show with Esau how are
you my brother I'm getting hungry let
how are you I'm doing Allah praise to
the critter heavens in the earth before
I was starting I was starting off and I
was gonna like you know going to your
whole biography but I mean it's not mess
it up okay let's bring you on and you
can kind of go ahead and talk to us a
little bit about yourself I mentioned
and an opening that you were born in
Serbia is that right that's in Europe
former Yugoslavia yeah
Hungarian background yeah live have
lived almost your whole life in Canada
yeah exactly
okay tell us talk to us about this okay
so I was born in Serbia and I was a year
old when my parents moved here to Canada
and so I've lived pretty much my entire
life in Toronto Canada I've visited back
home quite a few times and on my recent
trip back home I got a chance to travel
a little bit more throughout the region
you know to such places as Bosnia which
was really nice and you did the Bosnia
yeah that'd been to Bosnia and that was
my last trip in Europe that I went on
with my family and it was just after I
had I accepted Islam you know so your
parents did come from a Catholic
background Christian background yep so I
was baptized confirmed and also also had
my first communion as well as a Catholic
yeah now you know the whole purpose of
the show is really promoting purpose of
life for people to really think and
ponder absolutely ask those serious
questions you know where did I come from
you just popped up in this world right
there's a moment in time we didn't exist
then we were in the room and now we're
in this world and now and pretty soon
we'll be in the tomb so really to get
people to reflect about the importance
of you know knowing your purpose in life
living your purpose in life and you
started to ask these these important
questions you started to ponder and
think at a young age
around 1920 yeah what stimulated that 20
years old well I must say it was it was
through meeting a very nice brother and
it was through him that I actually got
introduced to Islam and from that point
on I definitely started to research
and study read the translation of the
Quran and also go to different messages
in Toronto I went to I had the honor of
going to the first journey of faith
conference where I was delighted to to
run into you and I had been watching
some of your shows this was right at the
beginning of when I actually was looking
into Islam and I had actually accepted
Islam without without fully researching
it because I just simply knew through
the person who told me about Islam that
Islam is Islam was that was it was the
truth I was I was I was totally I would
say convinced mm-hmm so we explained
that again someone says okay so you
accepted it because someone had provided
you with the evidence is the proves you
were convinced from everything they told
you what they tell you well see it was
more I would say more through his his
actions that I was convinced I saw that
he had very strong faith I thought you
know I just saw saw in him a lot of
sincerity a lot of genuine kill care for
other people and he's somebody that you
know has helped a lot of people and I
was I was definitely fortunate enough to
to have met him when when I at a point
in my life I was ready to change now
someone says look mother Teresa helped a
lot of people she fed a lot of poor you
know what I mean so it could have been
just the other way around you could have
met some some other person who was a
Hindu who was helping a lot of good
people helping a lot of people good
character you know what if somebody came
at you and said you know look you want
me to really think about purpose of life
and you know what's so special about
this Deen this way you know besides that
what else was it that I mean I
definitely had my I had doubts at the
beginning I would definitely say I had
my doubts you know those are those
questions coming tonight is this line
the truth is this really the way you
know so I could definitely say the best
they say the best cure for ignorant is
knowledge so I would definitely say
that's exactly what I did I was doing my
research I was talking to people I was
talking to Imams in Toronto I was I was
meeting brothers you know convert to
Islam hearing their stories that's
actually what really helped me a lot
at the beginning was listening to other
people's stories how and why they came
to Islam and that really just you know
solidified solidified it for me you know
all the research I did all the people I
talked to and you know after I did that
research that's when I was I was fully
convinced and about five or six months
after is when I fully started practicing
is my first Ramadan I started praying I
the chance to go to a Middle Eastern
country Dubai for three weeks with some
very nice brothers and that experience I
definitely would say changed my life
completely now there's somebody out
there I'm sure they just can't get past
the beard so someone's thinking like
look this guy like you know he's what
what is uh why is he going to beard now
what's with the beard tell us hmm well I
mean quite honestly I have you had a
problem with your family or somebody you
know that just was it gives you a hard
time because like my mom gives me a
little bit of a hard time my groundless
as well he said why why are you growing
up here why don't you shave it off and
quite honestly you know I'm not growing
it for my mom my grandmother's other
people you know I'm doing is simply to
follow that which the Prophet Muhammad
sallallaahu I do you sell them you know
told his uh his followers to do so
that's uh you know simply the reason why
why I'm doing it now your name okay your
name was Greg yeah now technically you
don't have to change your name no right
okay why did you choose to change your
name to Issa well it's quite an
interesting story I had I met that
Albanian brother who had introduced me
to his lab because formerly I didn't
really have much exposure to Islam and
Muslims you know I grew up in that area
whereas mostly Catholics and also fairly
big Jewish community so those are the
you know people that I grew up with in
in in Toronto and so after I had met him
he he was saving my my name well he
forgot my name and he happened to save
my my name in his phone as Issa and the
next time that I met with him he told me
so that he had saved my name is ISA and
I just said you know what
that's a very nice name it's the name of
Jesus peace be upon him so I just from
that point on decided that I like that
name and it's you know stuck with me
cents so that's actually the name of
that mighty messenger that no Muslim is
a Muslim as he believes in Jesus peace
be upon him isn't that's what your name
is named after absolutely sis yeah
absolutely Jesus had a beard
yeah absolutely okay Moses had a beard
yeah Abram had Abraham had a beard yeah
all these mighty messengers had a beard
and not only the last funnel mister
problem but all of them so yeah it's
amazing that you know Muslims who are
praying like Jesus who are greeting each
other with peace like Jesus's who are
refraining from you know keeping the
commandments like Jesus did yeah
we're continuing that tradition that
being that way of life exactly so at
what point now you're a young man yeah
and you're thinking you're contemplating
did you start asking yourself okay you
know those important questions what's
the purpose of life you know why am I
here where am I going when I die did you
start contemplating that what around
what time was that in your life
absolutely I would say what when I was
20 when I'm one of the main first
questions that this brother whose name
is Abdul Rahman actually told me I saw
he asked me he says what do you think
were to happen to you if you were to
just simply die you know die like that
just living a life of just always having
fun going out you know having a
girlfriend and just being heedless of
you know what our purpose here in life
is and what's what's actually gonna
happen to us once we die and I remember
just putting my head down and saying and
thinking to myself that I didn't want to
die I didn't want to die like that I
didn't want to die where I was I wasn't
living a life that you know I was I was
happy with and you know I I definitely
wanted to change and you know that's
that's the one question that really
really made me think and definitely my
journey began from there to research and
find out what happens to us once we die
and you know that we ought to we ought
to die it in its in a state
we're we're we're in a state of peace
where we're happy with ourselves we're
happy with the type of life that we're
living we're gonna we're going to take a
break and we come back with more
continue on with your story and your
experiences here in the Dean show we'll
be right back I started asking deeper
questions the question I want people to
really ask themselves is when you come
back from a night on the town
you've been drinking you've been boozing
you've been dancing video hanging out
with girls guys whatever number one did
you improve yourself is human being
number two did you contribute anything
to the betterment of humanity the
amazing thing is is that the most
advanced studies in psychology about
human happiness show that these are the
two key factors in making people
profoundly happy I take five minutes out
of my day and prayed to the Creator and
none of the creations and I feel a deep
internal peace and I still have my
normal life
back here in the Dean show with Greg
Issa and you were asked by a Muslim yeah
okay you are asked like and at that
point of your life you're not living a
good organic wholesome life obviously
right right so now he's asking you you
know what happened what would happen if
you died right now mm-hmm
and then you what happened from there
well I would definitely say you know
after that point I the brothers were
very very kind very nice they gave me an
English translation the quran the noble
quran they they brought me for jihad
they brought me to the masjid and from
from that point on i just really started
to look into what islam was because at
that point I didn't really know much
about Islam and that's when I started to
really research read the English
translation of the Quran again meet with
other people who are more knowledgeable
ask them questions and at the same time
you know look into other faiths as well
because Islam doesn't you don't
encourage us to be stay ignorant and
encourage us to learn to understand to
you know feel free to look into other
faiths it's not like Islam is the only
faith that exists and where we shouldn't
look into any other other faiths so I
definitely took the time then which I
didn't before to look into Christianity
see what Christianity was all about what
it taught you know things about the
Bible what the Bible is teaching and I
definitely you know looked into other
other religions at the same time which I
hadn't done previously
so it actually encouraged me to learn
understand about Judaism more about
Christianity more and about other faiths
as well and at the same time I was
learning about what what islam teaches
about for example Jesus and I had no
idea before I became Muslim that Muslims
believed in Jesus as a prophet and a
messenger and they believed in the
miracles of Jesus that he was born
miraculously without without a father
and that he performed miracles these
were all things that were definitely new
to me and looking back on that and
knowing now because I still have all he
see a lot of family members and and old
friends that still don't have have you
know still don't
know things about Islam such as the fact
that we believe we believe in ISA as a
prophet and a messenger of God it's it's
really amazing that you know so many
people are still in a situation where
they don't have peace in life right
because they're not living purpose so
you see many of you know human beings
who are emulating someone you know we
want to emulate that's why we ask you
about the beard yeah you know we want to
emulate the best of people
absolutely imitate the prophets of God
because they were the ones who are
teaching us how to get close to God so
do you feel like now you know with full
conviction that if anyone investigates
this Deen yeah using the faculties that
the Creator has given us yeah your brain
your reasoning you know and and at all
everything that God is giving that
you'll come that a person will come to
to know that this is definitely away
from the Creator
no doubt about it absolutely absolutely
and and I look at it in the way also is
that people go to university and spend
four years of their lives they spay for
their education they wake up in the
morning they study for their exams and
all simply for a diploma so that they
could get a better job I would just
encourage everybody to spend even a
litany not that much time maybe not four
years of their time but at least put
forward somewhat of an effort somewhat
of an effort into researching about the
Quran but what the Quran says about the
prophets look into what Christianity
says as well you know and I compare the
two and I believe anybody that's sincere
has it has has a sincere intention and
is truly looking for the truth that that
they will find it yeah it's it's I mean
I'm just the more you know I look into
it the more I investigate it the more
I'm convinced about it because it really
stimulates the mind it's not something
where we're blindly following it's based
on its truth based on proof right
evidence right so you know and you see
like you know you follow if you follow
some of the news some of the you know
things that are going on I was just
reading like recently I don't know
you had a Randy Travis he's like a
big-time country singer okay you know I
wanted just to bring this up yeah a lot
of people they emulate the superstars
the celebrities yeah but if you see
their lives they're upside down yeah he
was just caught you know driving drunk
combated with the police they found him
naked you know wow so this is a country
superstar right and you have people like
Miley Cyrus there's like a big hit in
Canada over there Drake Drake Heath Rana
oh he was just in a fight with the Chris
guy what's his name Chris Brown Chris
Brown in a nightclub and he's busted up
did you read about that no I'm not
really following this yeah you know you
just sometimes you read the Yahoo news
and usually you see all this you know or
all this drama that's out there and
obviously you can see that these
celebrities who aren't most of them in
Celebrity Rehab with dr. Drew yeah you
heard about that and their lives are
upside down they've have substance abuse
you know many of them are suicidal
they're on crack on meth on all sorts of
coke and all sorts of dope right and
their life so upside up because they
don't have purpose they have money but
they don't have purpose right do you run
into some of your old friends and family
people who still aren't you know live in
purpose live in you know how the creator
wants them to live and how your
experience has been now with the the the
have you had some hostility also from
people from back home from Hungaria or
family members now that you've accepted
his way Dean this way of life I would
say at the beginning I did have some
hostility when it came to my sister and
my dad not so much my mom my mom's
definitely been very supportive of me
throughout the last four four and a half
years but I do see with my old friend
with my old friends there are a few
years older than me and and I know I
know for a fact that they're getting
sick and tired of that lifestyle of
always going out always you know chasing
girls and doing you know they know that
lifestyle has nothing good to offer at
the end it's it's something that that
people imagine in their minds that is
fun it's exciting and and it's only when
they follow through with it that they
realize that it has had there's no
substance when you live that that type
of lifestyle and you know we were we
were meant to
mentioning Drake before and
interestingly enough I found out
recently through a friend that he
actually has a copy of the Quran in his
apartment in Toronto he does yeah this
is to a friend yeah my god almighty
creator guy to me Allah guide him man
yeah definitely so tell us now you have
you have you as a new Muslim you know
now how how you said your mom supportive
yeah how about your father and your
sister they're giving you a hard time
have you been able to share and tell us
for for I know we all make mistakes and
sometimes you know we look back and say
man I wish I could have did some things
different right so for some of the
numerous loves people have accepted this
way of life right now they can learn
from your experiences some of the the
do's and don'ts some things that you
would encourage them to do not to do
right yeah absolutely absolutely I mean
I would say at the beginning because my
sister and my father were a little bit
hostile you know I I was a little bit
impatient I was a little bit impatient
and got upset at certain things that
they did certain things that they said
and looking back on it truly now I mean
you know I I just wish that I could have
done a little bit more when it came to
still keeping those communication I
still still keeping with those
communications when it comes to Islam
with my father with with my sister I
mean unfortunately now because there was
a bit of hostility I just kind of had
the attitude is you know what I'd rather
not even talk about it with them but
that's definitely not the right approach
I mean you know we should always as
everyone knows we should always keep
good relationships with our families
with our fathers with our sisters with
our with our mothers and and talk to
them about Islam
try to find creative ways of bringing it
up or finding other people that could
talk to them about Islam and we should
always stay steadfast and trying to give
dower to our family members and you know
and just simply simply do our door best
and endure part because that's all we
could do is in the nicest way convey the
message to them and and pray for them
that Allah puts puts puts that puts Iman
puts faith into their heart we're gonna
take a break and we right back with more
fiber
I saw here on the Dean show do you think
these things are going to bring you
happiness
you know why you keep going back to the
club and you keep going back to these
desires because you never find
satisfaction it's going to end up
causing you if it hasn't already a lot
of pain what we are offering in Islam
what we have found in Islam for
ourselves is a means by which our hearts
are in peace they're at rest they're not
discontent we are pleased with what we
have
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
back here in addy show and we're talking
with our brother Issa talking to us
about your experiences how you came to
this beautiful way of life what was what
was it at the end okay you said that you
met this his brother and his character
yeah really you know had a profound
impact on you and you just you know he
invited you to Salaam and you accepted
Islam yes I mean for the most part a lot
of people they study Islam fully but I
think you know why why take a year or
two years why wait years why wait you
know once you know once you are you know
you shouldn't really think about what
what's gonna be the consequences of me
accepting Islam see I never thought of
those things I just simply you know had
had a lot of trust in this brother
because I just saw from his sincerity
you know his his character and like how
strong his faith was and the things that
he was telling me like he was truly
trying to help me get out of the
struggles that I was going through in my
life and and I just knew that what what
he believed him was truly the way I just
I just I just truly knew at that point
and I didn't think of the consequences
of oh what's my what are my friends
gonna think you know what's gonna happen
what are other people going to think
because I truly believe a lot of people
are actually a slave to those types of
those things they're always worried
about okay you know how they look what
what do whether or whatever friends
think what are people at work gonna say
what what are what are other people
going to think of me and when you're
always trying to impress when you're
always trying to impress your other
people you're actually not being
yourself you know you're just you know
you're just always
a simply asleep - that you know is are
other people around you gonna accept you
definitely you see a lot of people
procrastinating mm-hmm and I've had this
experience talking to a lot of people
and then they know it's like you know
they know that this is the truth but
because of the surrounding factory plans
you know what other people going to say
it's like they put it away put it away
put it to the side and they just keep on
with life yeah so you know this is a
good advice don't procrastinate yeah
exactly yeah that's the truth be upon
the truth exactly yeah so tell us more
now you've gotten also to what were what
were besides your family what we're also
some some challenging because life is a
test obviously we're gonna be tested so
what were some of the other challenges
being a new Muslim and these challenges
that you had and you overcame and how
did you overcome them right I'll
probably see the the biggest challenge
was I I decided I completely wanted to
change so I left off that lifestyle of
drinking and going out and just you know
being around friends that I knew we're
gonna negatively influence me so I
totally left off those friends and you
know at the beginning it was hard
because there was a lot of times it
became fairly lonely I didn't I didn't
know anybody I hadn't grown up around
Muslims I didn't know any you know I
didn't have any friends I would say that
and that was probably the biggest
difficulty at the beginning but I handle
all praise be to Allah that Allah
replaces those old friends with much
much greater friends that I'm definitely
blessed to have today and what I could
simply say is for the new Muslims at the
beginning to be it's gonna be it's gonna
be a little bit tough it's gonna be a
little bit tough and you know it
definitely gives you a time to build
that relationship with Allah when when
you're in those times of loneliness and
you know what I could say to two Muslims
if you see a new Muslim or somebody that
you've never seen before at the Masjid
go up to him you don't ask him how he's
doing what his name is you know how long
he's been Muslim you know invite him out
with you know some brothers and just
just show that
in hospitality that that true Muslims
that true Muslims have and that was
probably my biggest challenge and that's
what I try to do today if I know someone
just became Muslim I'll get his contact
information I'll say hey I'll come pick
you up I'll bring you for Juma for
Friday prayers you know I'll introduce
you to some like brothers in the Masjid
and you know simply take him out and you
know just try to show them a bit of hot
any bit of hospitality that I can now
before we cut out and show is almost
over you know obviously we can
understand you know a lot of times you
know people look at this Deen this way
of life as the other so now you become a
Muslim and let's say your parents they
think that maybe look he's become a
terrorist or something obviously Islam
has nothing to do with that right so you
know but now when they get to know what
we believe and they see that Islam is
actually beautiful it's calling a person
have peace with their creator with
themselves and the rest of their
humanity become a better son to become a
better and more honest human being and
you're more moral in your life and you
have more compassion and love and good
character now you know for those people
you know your father and whoever else is
out there from your family you know that
maybe might get to watch the show you
know and and they were a little bit
reluctant to have you explain because
they were so on the defensive you know
and other people on the world who might
be from hungry watching it or from
Serbia or whoever and they just have no
idea about it's not what is it now so
what is it about Islam that really you
know changed your life and what are some
of the beliefs what do you believe now
do you believe in some you know Martian
from out of space or you know what do
you believe now what is it about Islam
and what do you believe well I would say
I would say Islam has really given
purpose purpose to my life and an Islam
is not a way of life that's boring by
any means you know Islam is such such a
beautiful way of life that there there's
always something new and interesting to
do you know we have our five daily
prayers we have our Friday prayers on
Friday where we go to the Masjid we hear
a nice lecture we
sometimes with brothers afterwards we
just had a Ramadan that just
unfortunately passed us and this this
past Ramadan was one of the one of the
greatest Ramadan's for sure the greatest
Ramadan that ever had and it was so nice
on II to give all the brothers you know
big nice hugs like after Eid and
inshallah I'll be also going to going
for Hajj as well and I mean you know
there's definitely nothing you know that
you should be bored with there's always
something to do you know there's always
something new to learn new to new to do
and at the same time we should also be
calling people to Islam you know that's
that that's very important and but
obviously before that we have to know
what Islam is we have to seek that
knowledge we have to go to the right
sources we have to learn from our
scholars from our Imams out at our mud
kids and truly understand what Islam is
implement and to implement it into our
lives and and then also call of course
call other people to it and Islam is
very simple it is it is the only pure
monotheistic faith on the earth there's
no there's no other faith that is as
that is pure monotheistic suisse we
simply believe that there's only one God
worthy of worship and that we should
follow his commands and we should follow
the examples of all the prophets and
messengers that God has sent us we we
live according to the books that he has
revealed to his messengers and the last
and final book that he has revealed to
all of mankind so till the day of
judgement is of course the Quran and we
should try to really read it and
internalize it and and just just simply
live according to the Quran to the best
best of our ability and a part of
following the Quran is of course
following the Sunnah which is the way of
the Prophet Muhammad sallallahu alayhi
wa sallam and we should study about we
should look into his biography you know
how he treated his his enemies how he
treated his friends his wives his
children
and we should truly you know we should
truly always look at the best of
creation and the best of examples which
were the prophets and messengers of God
Almighty and we should do our best at
all times to just live according to
their way the way of life that they live
and try to really establish that
establish that relationship with our
Creator and you know and really put an
emphasis on on establishing the prayer
that that is that is very important we
need to at the beginning discipline
ourselves and it's funny I heard
something recently that you know
somebody I was listening to said you
know they would always tell their mother
you know oh I I have to pray and the mom
would say why do you have to pray and
then and then from I have to pray it
became - I need to pray I want to pray
and at the beginning it does have his
challenges is establishing the prayer
but it definitely is very important and
after our belief in one God and after a
belief and the last and final messenger
of God we definitely need to put a lot
of emphasis on the prayer prayer prayer
yes definitely and we can't go wrong
where should be only God praying to one
God doing good being good thank you very
much for being with us on today's show
it's always a pleasure to talk to people
like yourself and get to share your
experiences with the viewers of the Deen
show may God Almighty the creator award
you for being with us thank you thank
you very much and thank you again for
sitting through another episode of the
Deen show another human beings story
another person's story on how they came
to this beautiful Deen and how they live
in purpose living according to God's
will not their desires and that's what
life is all about you got one shot to
get it right and at the end we die and
then we die and then I see the Paradise
or the Hellfire so we're going to follow
those individuals who are not bringing
us closer to the Creator
bad company bad friends that are just
bringing out the worst in you you
smoking dope drinking not kool-aid but
I can coke and you're smoking dope and
you're lying deceiving cheating and
you're not living a good wholesome life
you're not happy you're gambling your
whole life away not only are you
gambling but you gather in the whole
life away and and and you're not living
your purpose and you're not happy you're
not content you'll never be content
until you live according to God's game
plan and you got one shot to get it
right one life and if you're watching
this episode and you like what I just
had to say really contemplate and think
ask the Creator ask him alone to guide
you only God and if you can understand
that and you like that only praying to
God not having to go in a confession box
10 Hail Marys praying to a man to a
woman to a stick to a stone to a bone no
you only pray to God he's the only one
that could forgive you no one in
creation but to the one who created
creation the one creator you pray to Him
and ask him right now you could have
done the worst of things but right now
it's your chance ask the Creator to
guide you ask the Creator because if you
ask then you shall receive but if you
keep going and living in life a heedless
life life and debauchery just find your
lesson desires
what's gonna happen to them when you die
just like our guest when he was asked
that question what if you died right now
deaf came upon you it's over is done
don't let it come to that ask to create
it right now to guide you repent for
your sins and start living a good
wholesome organic life and you can call
us at any time 1-866 to Islam don't
forget to pick up the new dunya to Dean
and visit us here every week on the Dean
show we'll see you next time God willing
until then peace be unto you
[Music]
just me not hundred assalamualaikum
greetings of peace to everybody how are
you you come to get some food for the so
you've been replete with everything
house but it's not satisfying the soul
money can't buy that happiness it won't
bring you peace not even a six-pack of
peace you can't buy it
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this is the theme this is the
[Music]